[Music]
thanks everybody for coming out for
another night of the semi Slav so I know
some people we've got some new faces
here which is always cool thanks for
coming tonight we're going to be going
over part four you agree with that part
four of the semi Slav and we've been
looking at the Moran for the last three
weeks all sorts of different lines
tonight we're going to look at the anti
Moran's especially the positional ones
and then next class we'll have something
extra special are you familiar with this
opening at all this is the the Slav and
black makes sort of a triangle and we're
still looking at lines where white plays
III in a couple of weeks we're going to
start looking at some of the really
sharp fun fireworks that can occur after
Bishop to g5 we're still looking at the
move III and black makes a useful
developing move and so far we've only
been looking at the move Bishop to d3
which is the most natural developing
move you just put a bishop on the most
active square and then obviously black
can take on c4 and play b5 and get all
the stuff we've been looking at so far
all month but as we sort of noticed and
it did take three weeks to get through
it's because it's super theoretical the
lines with Bishop to d3 here which is
not for everybody's taste and some
people kind of want to avoid all of that
theory completely if that's possible so
we're gonna look at the move Queen to
see to what just makes a nice useful
developing move the queen is nice on c2
we have more control over e4 and we're
just waiting we're saying well black now
it doesn't really make any sense for you
to take here since I just get to develop
on my own terms so I played a useful
move and we could have had this position
you know if you had if I played Bishop
to d3 so I've just made a useful move
and I've improved over that position so
instead what black tends to do here is
he himself plays his own useful move
Bishop to d6 and this is where we're
going to start and we're actually going
to look at three moves over the next two
weeks today we're going to look at the
positional anti Maroons b3 which seems
to be popular at club level so we'll
have a look at this and you know
relatively very strong players have have
played this way so it's a decent weapon
Bishop d3 is the main move so we'll
definitely have a look at this today and
then next week assuming we get through
all of this because you never know and I
don't really want to rush in this series
if we can avoid it next week we're going
to look at g4 and we're gonna have a
little fun and hopefully there'll be a
lot of audience participation and
playing in this move so for those in the
audience you can go prep this all week
and then come face the class with it
next week so we're going to look at the
Shabab shear of gambit which is
obviously very sharp you're just gamba
ting your jeep on what's that all about
we'll have a look at that next week
let's start with the move b3 this is
where we're going to begin our coverage
tonight the move b3 white just
solidifies the center so now if you ever
take on c4 I can just take back with a
pawn okay very reasonable
so we castle and now White's move here
might kind of surprise you it's about
time we develop this Bishop and then we
castle but what Square should we go to
and it might surprise you that the most
popular move is actually Bishop to e2 it
may appear that this is a more active
square for the bishop which is true
that's a better Square for the bishop
however sometimes you're going to run
into problems after E 5 with the threat
of efore and black is castled and white
hasn't and it's not to say this is a bad
move at all for what you can certainly
play this way so we'll have a look at a
couple of the lines here before we go
back to Bishop to e2 which is the more
common path b5
and you know I've been having this
discussion with some people here there's
an almost automatic move in this type of
structure when they play e5 before you
do anything like you capture on e5 or
you do any of that
the almost automatic move is C takes d5
this at least means that black is going
to have a slightly compromised pawn
structure because now if we ever take on
e5 you're going to end up with an
isolated D pawn so black should be ready
for that when he plays this way
okay the thread is efore so there's
actually two moves here you can take on
e5 or you can play Knight to b5 we'll
look at these both just very briefly so
if you take we can go here and the most
common move is actually to take and
after Bishop to b2 the reason white
doesn't play this way a lot is well for
one probably we can just play d4 and get
rid of this pawn right away which would
be sort of which would equalize just
because all of our pieces get out
reasonably well we can also play rook to
e8 this is actually the more common way
to do it and to play for a little more
and I think here once you either Castle
kingside or play Knight to e2 those are
popular moves but surprisingly a lot of
people also Castle queenside which also
feels a little bit dubious because
there's a whole lot of error over here
by your King and I know like computers
hate it but some people have played this
way and it's an aggressive dynamic way
for white to try to play so these things
are all possible but uh it's nothing
really special or anything that blacks
should worry about if white decides to
play this way another interesting move
is Knight to b5 which is a recurring
theme in lots of these lines so if you
play the semi Slav you're going to this
is going to be a move you might run into
a lot of the time so our Bishop is
attacked so we can check and after they
block now White has to take back with a
knight otherwise eforp and with the
bishop on d3 we get to gain this tempo
so this won't be true if the bishop had
already started on e2 so we'll look at
that in a minute
and okay among other moves we have this
move a six and here white can do a
couple different things you can go back
to c3 and again this is just nothing too
special for white okay if the white
wants to play this way he has no real
advantage at all also he can consider
this move which is interesting also it's
a little riskier because your knight can
sometimes get trapped in there it
doesn't have a whole lot of places that
can go and here actually we get to do a
very special maneuver especially for us
local people we get to play rook a7 and
what is this rook called the Machuca
rook yeah Danny Machuca is one of our
teachers he's one of our best teachers
here he does a great job and he's sort
of famous for this rook move he always
plays rook a7 there and in certain lines
so you know sometimes it's good
sometimes it's bad it's like any other
move but he's famous for doing that so
around here we like to call up the
Machuca
rook very good and yeah so why why can
play this way he's probably just gonna
play rook to see wand and those lines
are interesting as well well let's come
back to the main course here instead of
going to most active square Bishop e2
and what's funny is after developing all
the pieces and castling and stuff
sometimes white in the future will
actually end up playing this move he
just doesn't want to play it right away
because it runs into an immediate 'if
I've with at least equality for black
and okay again you can play the move e5
in this position that's a very possible
move the most popular move though is b6
and this is sort of important in this
type of structure on the sounds on so
when Ben Simon hears this again he's
going to like that in general any
structures black wants to just be really
really patient that's what you tend to
do so you play b6 Bishop e7 Queen e7 and
then you you wait and see what white
does and you put your books in all the
right places and then eventually you
play e5 or c5 if you got to get one of
those breaks in as black you can play
the move e5 which I don't think is
actually a bad move at all
again sort of the automatic reaction in
this bone structure they can take and
now if we go in for this same line
so after this check this is actually a
little bit better for team white here
because this doesn't come with tempo
anymore
so that's sort of a big difference so
you can get a position like this which
should actually be quite fine for both
sides we can try to trade this guy so
the audience doesn't see it you at home
see it though so it's just some
continuation like this might be possible
where black does have this isolated deep
on but he does get a lot of activity we
notice just how active these Knights are
the Queen's coming in etc and so you
have to get some sort of really active
play and what is not very close to even
putting any pressure at all on this deep
on so this should be roughly equal so
you can if you like playing these kinds
of positions as either side you can go
for it but you obviously don't have to
rush for this position
instead of playing the move e5 here you
can just play b6 and again the idea is
we're going to develop we're gonna move
our pieces decide where these rooks go
etc all right so white always castles
here this should be seven
and then there's a couple moves that
people just develop all of their stuff
the bishop goes on b2 the queen goes on
e7 and now it's actually interesting so
here white kind of has to make the first
decision and this one that I think is
tough for a lot of club players where to
put the rooks and there's actually kind
of two ideas so we're going to look at
two different games in these types of
positions well you can put your rooks on
D 1 and C 1 so we'll get this you can
also put the other rook on D 1 and put a
rook on e 1 so white kind of has to
decide how he wants to play and the good
news for black is as a general rule in
this exact position it would obviously
varies in other positions
whatever white does you copy him if he
puts his rooks on the E and D file you
can put your books on the E and E file
and that's always right so it's kind of
easy in that sense for remembering where
black should put his stuff you just copy
what white does in this type of position
so first of all this look at this move
which I think it's actually the more
common way to play so white is going to
play with rooks on d1 and e1 when we
look at this interesting game between
Ernst and Geary and I like this one only
because this is you as much theory this
is the main main main line for this anti
Moran variation with b3 so why decides
is where he puts his rooks and black
simply copies
okay and now we see Bishop d3 and we're
still waiting so black well at some
point have to pick is he going to play
e5 or is it going to play c5 and in this
game you went ahead with the move e5 so
the almost automatic response here from
white taking on d5 and we recapture and
now we're threatening to play e4 so he
took and after we take back again we get
a position where black has an isolated D
pawn but what is you know kind of
surprising in a position like this for
people that aren't used to this is very
often it's black that can get a big
initiative and an attack going because
these bishops are great these Knights
are great the Queen can come in it's
easy to get these these rooks into the
action so it's actually can happen
rather quickly that black gets an
initiative
in which position when white takes on d5
after E for did you give me those okay
sue I'm sorry I can take here
that's what do you say in my crush on
you
yeah it looks like blacks Bollywood me
no okay let's try to figure it out why
don't we play e4 let's see stakes so if
here I guess I can take here now that's
probably the point yes I don't think I
have to just strictly Holbrook ca ca
Bishop takes e4 yeah you like might see
a rook c8
and I would not have six now if Queen
takes and we do this and take something
yeah so that's so it's actually
interesting but yeah I think I can take
and then take on c6 and then yeah I
didn't what you're going to do here
because I think work c8 even saves you
it's a good question though
okay so he took here which is it's
around back and yet might surprise you
that this is the main move and this is
still a dozen games or so so in this
position black has managed to get the
bishop pair so he has these two bishops
and they're you know very good at
attacking white however has the
positional plus because black has this
isolated pawn and that's why people like
to play this as white it's a very
positional way to play against the semi
Slav so players that want to try to
exploit this in the long run and it's
already blockaded so there's a lot of
good things going for you that's why
people would play this as white and then
we're not going to watch this whole game
because we've got a lot of games to show
you tonight but they play the whole
bunch of maneuvers and the game was just
equal forever and ever and ever but I
get Geary I was playing with black here
world class so he found this move so now
pause your videos and see if you can
find okay I gave it away too quick and I
did that when I showed it to somebody
else earlier today too but so I haven't
actually looked at this in like five
weeks cuz I prepared all these lectures
like all at once so I don't I don't
remember any of these games yeah yeah so
Queen h5 check exactly and he went here
which is a big blunder he should go back
to g1 and then we can take this so that
was his point so he stole upon and the
computers will still say zero zero zero
doesn't matter that you lost upon
opposite bishops and the same pawns and
etc so yeah even though there you have
that little tactic in computers not
impressed okay
it's not impressed but instead he went
here which was very unfortunate because
now ya g5 with an elementary mate in
nineteen but yeah Queen ish for check is
annoying I mean you have like a couple
checks but then you lose
so here the game ended he played he
found g5 I don't know what white
obviously just didn't see that but if he
just goes back the computer doesn't care
that you lost upon equal equal equal
equal equal 0 0 0 0 0 it doesn't matter
H 1 doesn't matter but by trying to go
up to not lose his stuff he lost the
game okay so that's one interesting game
let's return it let's go all the way
back let's just go all the way back the
fun just so we can see this one more
time so tonight we're looking at Queen
c2 so we have to make some useful
developing move and we're still looking
at the move b3 okay we Castle we're
looking at Bishop e2 this is the main
line map Bishop d3
and now we're just going to develop
everybody develops all of their stuff
okay now let's have a look at another
game where white decides to play rook to
d1 and rook to c1 and this is the game
between choocha loave and Sharov it was
played in 2009 shear off it's always
good to watch his games in these lines
he's an expert at the semi Slav him and
Anand are are very very good they have
very good results with it so when you
see a shear off game you probably want
to watch it if you're studying a
database with these games he's very good
so he copied white very professional
that's what you just copy and he got off
of the B file because there was a rook
on the same file as his queen and a6
which means he's probably going to play
C 5 so he's keeping control over b5 so
it looks like he's going to play C 5 and
he's not gonna let the night go to b5 so
white just Waits and C 5
so okay very patient play and as always
white tries to get a positional
advantage based on the pawn structure so
CD exactly any back and there's and now
he played here which isn't the greatest
move it's not so obvious why but okay
he's going to put his Bishop on on g2
what's wrong with that it's not so bad
you can go in from the hanging pawns so
he could consider this perhaps white
didn't want to do this because at some
point I can play d4 and if you just look
at blacks pieces we'll look at it in
this position I got all of these pieces
coming at you you know and then we can
do all of this this guy can come over
here we can do this and that's a lot of
scary arrows so black actually can get a
huge initiative an attack which is sort
of what you want to do whenever you know
you have the the weaker pawn structure
in the center you got to play
dynamically and get an attack and that's
a lot of scary arrows white for his part
I mean we can try to draw as many scary
arrows as we can but that's not as many
so we'll pretend like black is better
because that's what you guys want to
hear you clicked on a semi Slav lecture
you want to hear blacks better and every
line so well that's what that's what
we'll pretend you know white has a lot
less scary arrows so black is better you
guys like it yeah so he played g3 and
here black played the best move
which I guess might not be a very
obvious move I don't think it's so easy
to prove an advantage here with blank
but he found a way to do it played the
move c4 and perhaps given time I'll play
B 5 B 4 C 3 that would be a disaster if
I if I got the verities pawns on B 3 and
C 3 that would just be game over so you
have to you have to deal with that
somehow obviously we don't really want
to take because that just opens up this
bishop so what he decided to do is the
move
a4
and so black took here and now white
made a mistake sort of overlooking the
attacking potential of Black Knight to
d2 he's just going to go win this pawn
with this Knight but now he's bringing
all his pieces away from his King so we
haven't really gone into his territory
over there but well we're thinking about
doing it soon and black now actually
played a very aggressive move and it's
it's definitely the right way to play
here so you can pause at home and ask
the audience here I'm gonna see if you
guys can play like Shirov so your
opponent is going away from his king so
94 is interesting isn't it
or maybe Age 5
yeah so here let me just continue with
this move did you have this is
interesting even y94 looks propagator
looks like you can take on d5 after you
can take on d5 after white what after
what everywhere here where do you want
to blunder your knight you join blunder
it now or next move okay
plate age five yeah so he's trying to
create some weaknesses he's gonna play
h4 and he's going to take on g3 and I'm
not going to tell you why white can't
play h4 here I'm not going to tell you
because that's the tactic that will
happen in the game so h4 would be a big
blunder so he did go here and now black
plays H for himself and white plays the
most natural move and this is a total
blender so so thank you what do you guys
play is black so this is this is why I
really like this game we're going to
show off you know the tactical ability
of she robbed it was obviously known
what's that
sure yep so HG 383 Bishop d3 is exactly
what was played excellent OOP
excellent and white can't take so he
didn't if you take here the big problem
is we're taking here and you're in a lot
of trouble for example if you go here
I'm going here
this is not going to be very pleasant
for you if here I can go here do some of
that stuff so no matter what you do I
mean here's no better I think it's the
same I can go here and you don't really
have a good way of stopping this for
example I don't know here then we have
here
I guess you can block here but okay if
you go here in here so there's some
issues you can't really take it and you
know align so this is the kind of tactic
that you want to look for they moved all
their stuff away from the Kings you kind
of want to open them up and and now he's
up a pond so for the next couple moves
where again we're going to speed through
it tonight so you just you know some
slow maneuvering and he's up a pond so
he's just better forever and ever and
we'll get to the final move which was
also brilliant so we're good we're
getting closer here if three and this is
a mistake so they've been just
maneuvering around in blacks just been
happy up upon for a long time now and
again white pushes upon in front of his
King and that's a mistake but how do you
punish it this one is a lot tougher
let's give that other one 1x glam let's
move to X clams rope takes F 3 all right
yeah you can go into puzzle club so all
right good job Dennis
so yeah you take on f3 and you again you
can't take it back
the point is if King takes Queen up 5
you know you're going to get checkmated
if Bishop takes this one is a little bit
tougher
Queen c2 and whatever you do there's
gonna be some attack here and I haven't
studied this and however long oh oh but
if I remember right this is this is
funny
if for example you realize you're
getting mated and you play here the best
move is going to shock you okay this
this wins but also clean up - yeah
that's the that's the more professional
cooler way to do it and yeah and if here
you can now like take or something
there's some cooler way to do it but you
know that was like an eternity ago so
how would I ever how'd I ever remember
how to meet you and okay but there's
nothing you can do it so the point is
you can't really take it with it either
peace so he resigned in this position
now down to pawns and also now blacks
really crushing your hair okay okay so
that'll have to do it for the B three
line just check our time here
okay we're decent time
okay so we'll go all the way back to
this position again tonight we're
looking at the move Queen to c2 after we
develop our Bishop we're going to look
now at the mainline when you play the
anti Miranda system here as white Bishop
d3 and so this is a little bit different
than the regular Moran in that white has
the Queen on c2 like as a bishop on d6
okay and you can take on c4 now or the
next move it's after this here and this
is going to look a little bit more like
some of the Moran's that we've been
looking at all week in the sense that
after you take back we're going to play
moves like b5 Bishop e7 a 65 all the
normal stuff we seem to see here with
the Moran I also want to mention that
briefly we're look at some games there
wasn't a whole lot interest only I guess
only one person actually specifically
requested it but some people were hoping
in this position I mean obviously we
covered b5 here we covered this line
that we covered a six we've recovered
Bishop to b7 somebody did ask for the
move Bishop to d6 and so we're going to
cover that by transposition so remember
this position and both sides can Castle
so some of the games we're going to look
at tonight are going to be in that that
system where they they go back here okay
let's find where we are
okay so f Bishop d3 then is transposed
into that line and we're going to look
at this last the more popular move and
we're going to look at this last because
those have the coolest games of all time
so we're going to get a very similar
thing to the regular Moran again we're
going to play a 65 and that's how we're
going to liberate our bishop okay rook
d1 Queen c7 let's see and so we'll just
we'll look at this very briefly here
this is sort of the one of the main
lines and you get a position like this
is relatively equal you can play g3 D
takes e5 Bishop g5 looks like I have a
game here don't remember it
dooba say Wrigley 2012 and in this what
I do remember about these types of
position is when you take care of this
rook actually gets attacked a lot and
the computer always says no matter what
you do everything is always equal even
if your rooks like trapped so there's
probably lots of attacking of the rook
you get to attack the rook as many times
as you want just keep attacking the rook
yes I think here I think this was the
mistake in this game okay so this was
some game all right
Bensimon decide if that should actually
make the cut you'll decide okay but
we'll come back here and let's look at
this move here this is a much cooler
move Bishop to d3 it's led to some of
the most beautiful games in chess and I
do want to show you the best game of
chess ever played and like I mean it so
my favorite game I think it's one that a
lot of people might actually know
because it's so famous we'll get to it
so a3 okay you know you're going to play
d4 rook c8 and there's a lot more common
moves that you could play here obviously
you don't have to play rook to c8 it's
like the fourth most common move but
it's led to some very very very
fantastic games from this position very
sharp it gets very complicated so let's
let's enjoy this position here Knight g5
white attacks h7
now we'll wait a second to build
suspense eat what is it
right yeah the night bishop queen
so it's attacking it three times and
it's only defended twice bishop h2 check
okay let's check it out and you want it
to check me I guess I'll have to go back
and you want to take here and I take
here and some confusion it's actually
looks good for black doesn't it yeah
mm-hmm
nikka Pike King h1 it'd be more
complicated so I can play like h6 or
something yeah this is right so no
matter what you're going to get
something really complicated like this
it's going to be quite messy I think
this is actually an okay okay move here
yeah I think yeah I don't know if you
should take her and move over this is
actually interesting so I think this
actually could be played over here look
at two games that played an even more
fantastic move that's a move you might
consider we're looking to move that you
really would only play if you've done
lots and lots and lots of prep so C 5 C
5 all right you you attack my H pawn I
blunder my beep on if I hang pawns on
both sides of the board you won't be
able to take it all you'll be too
confused that's essential ok so black
just hammers through the move that he
wants to play and doesn't care about
what White's doing I wanted to play c5
and I did it what are you going to do
about it well we're going to look at two
different moves here probably the most
critical move is to take with the bishop
but I do want to show this game because
this is the greatest game of all time do
you know a game this is clutter you
might know this game yeah Aronian Anand
2012/2013 sorry if I can't if I can say
and yeah yeah yeah how's Anand very well
prepared and I I believe he said to this
was his World Championship prep for
Gelfand
and then Aronian unfortunately stumbled
into it so that's that's not good
world championship prep is pretty good
prep so everything is just like hanging
bla bla bla I don't care what you're
doing
Knight g4 and okay you can only do this
if you're really well-prepared because
you're hanging all of your stuff
well he played out for g3 which looks
like one way to do it actually I think
this is the best move there's this move
which is the trickiest but I don't think
it's that good yeah the point is if
you're here which is good for black but
I think actually he has f3 maybe even f4
you can play a move like this so I think
that actually refutes those so I think
you actually have to take here and yet
so the idea is is here so there's all
sorts of tricky stuff so g3 probably
can't be played h3 maybe can be played
but black is going to get a big
initiative and something like this
notice that this pawn is pinned so
sometimes I can take here something like
this could be really scary which
explains the move f4 now he simply just
takes just ignoring everything that's
hanging everywhere no big deal and white
took back and now black played the
greatest move in chess history until he
played his next move which was even
better so for a few minutes this next
move was the greatest move in chess
history for like a full minute yeah so
do pause here if you've never seen this
game some people have probably already
seen this because I think it's one of
the most famous games of all time but
what did black play here take about 300
million years to solve it and then
you'll still won't and only one person
will get that joke why 300 million yes
go ahead and pause your videos I'm only
asking you to play the greatest move in
chess history that's all I'm asking
ok I'm gonna give the answer away the
very very very shocking move Bishop c5
oh wow
yeah you don't get to play a move like
that too often and if you do it's
usually not right usually you're hanging
your bishop
but here it's actually really dangerous
to take it you did this before you
played Bishop c5 in a position like this
uh-huh
you played a bishop move blundering the
bishop rope reversal ah so you did this
against Daniel Barts so Mario Roper
knows all about this maneuver so that's
good you should start teaching here
private lessons yeah
yeah you want private lessons with Mario
Roper moved to st. Louis that's true
Bishop e2 was played in the game you can
maybe take this though I remember just
reading analysts and some of the I take
it don't take it people thought about
this for hours and hours so who knows
maybe you can maybe you can't you'd have
to you know waste a lot of your life to
figure out this position because even
the best people with all the best
engines I have a hard time sorting all
this out the best line might go
something like this and blacks better
maybe could be equal who knows
impossible to tell what's the material
count nobody can figure that out I
called NASA I said you know what's going
on here they're like we had no idea so I
have them working on it I'll let you
know when they report back to me so in
the game he played Bishop e2 which a
huge part of this position is actually
the f2 square so this is actually a
pretty bad move so we're trying to you
know in all these lines sometimes we
have lots of Knights that can go here as
we want Queens and bishops to go here
and so I think here andand actually had
to think on his own I think Bishop c5
was still prepped and here he had to
think on his own and he played the best
move in chess history which is good
because it's you know been a couple
minutes it's about time to play an even
better move so Bishop c5 easy yeah the
second best move right now now this I
mean this is why this game is famous
because the next game is also ridiculous
so you can't you can't figure it out if
you've never seen the game it's
impossible
Oh coño 1985 yeah right the fanciest
move yeah just simple centralization
obvious what's going on who knows and
now a simple technical task of just
winning the game from here no big deal
if you're 2,800 and we're ready for this
position yeah there's like you can't
take anything so he took this which i
think is the best move and then he
played all the best moves but he still
lost because now blacks winning unless
he's not the computer can't even tell
you it doesn't know anything like the
computer it doesn't even give an
evaluation here it's just like three
question marks you know it would be like
zero zero zero or maybe blacks winning
it's just just question marks that's all
it is even nobody knows and the
computers everything they like it and
now analyzes like wrong in this position
because it's ridiculously complicated
but here he took here and now black has
a winning idea if we could we would like
to put this Queen here because then
you're going to get checkmated and this
isn't going to help you you're going to
get checkmated however if we go here
directly White has a move to save the
game maybe who knows it's impossible to
know now but if here we can trade the
Queen's and then maybe this is better
for black but okay you didn't just
outright win so again another very nice
move he just took our rook but we want
to play Queen to h4 but we don't want to
allow Queen to h7 so very confusing
stuff
probably just taking back the night is
good for black it's probably different
like just taking back is probably good
for like I think I'm not material it's
impossible to know right it was not the
move that was played so how do we make
it possible to play Queen to h4 without
you know letting them drag queens my
kids do that they laugh it's mine
they tattoo that's true yeah they do a
lot of funny coughing so so what is the
move here for black you can sacrifice
your queen how you can do it
you play Queen e5 what way what when I
takes but then you take my queen I'm
gonna go here and then I'm going to take
your queen yeah pawn f5 good your name
was David all right good job and this is
your first class all right good job
f5 a really hard to move to play because
they just took your stuff you want to
take it back or you want to go check
meet them but f5 and now go ahead and
stop me from doing that well he did
Knight to g6 so it's a good start now
Queen f6 and okay these things are only
temporary after h3 which doesn't really
threaten anything we can just take here
notice if you go here we can go
somewhere over here whichever one you
think is prettier so instead this
happened and now one more little move
here another nice little move not the
best move ever but a little interference
notice that we want to take this right
because this pawn is pinned so we want
to take here because that would be
checkmate
so we need to find an interfering move
Bishop III and he he resigned uh I think
this is the best move um okay so
obviously that was just a truly
fantastic game a lot of it was prep and
actually let me in to see what you guys
think and what you guys think it tell me
in the comments some people think this
game was not beautiful because a lot of
it was computer preparation do you guys
think it's still truly beautiful chess
art even if you know your computer told
you to do it or does it have to be like
original coming from a human brain on
the spot yeah this was his prep for
Gelfand for the world champ so yeah a
lot of this was I think this moved
though he found on his own because
Bishop e2 is not a computer move at all
yeah so in my opinion which you can
agree or disagree let me know even if
it's a computer that like figured it out
it's still you know a very beautiful
game and I still appreciate it even if a
human didn't figure it out but feel free
to disagree that's that's up to you guys
okay I guess I guess we have one more
game that I also have totally forgotten
about let's just let's get to the main
position here one more time yeah maybe
we talked about that maybe we didn't
knows back to this position this was a
very interesting position after black
plays c5 there was a game played
upstairs at the Chess Club in this
position you guys might know that game
was played in 2015 this was the US
Championship Wesley so had white against
Sam 7 and this is probably the you know
more critical line and I think in this
game like a lot of mistakes were made so
we're going to rush through it unfairly
even though it's way too complicated and
requires hours and hours of analysis to
properly understand so in this position
what you can do here is black as you can
play g6 trapping the bishop however now
white
it's a whole bunch of pawns and it's
really really complicated and I assume
it's better for the person with all of
the pieces but it's usually a lot harder
to play with all the pieces so White's
going to get a big initiative but you
know he's playing Sam Semyon
it was also super good both these guys
are super good at tactics so this
position favors both of them so yes so
now again there's some material
imbalance that is difficult to calculate
don't even try it almost too hard and it
doesn't even really matter what matters
is after the motorcycle gang we pacify
it what matters is you know activity and
peace placement and stuff and what will
black be able to consolidate or will
white get a humongous attack here let's
see how do this game end
that's that's good move is to see really
complicated stuff and that's why you
play this is because it's like super
complicated and so we're not going to
bother so now I think black black didn't
get checkmated so now he's doing great
so I got to do is Mike a checkmated
needing get checkmated so now black
should win OOP okay and so here Wesley
so had to resign so and that's the kind
of thing to wear okay even if you're
playing a twenty eight hundred and Sam's
a decent Grandmaster especially I don't
how old he was he was 13 when he became
like a GM here so he's he was still
young at this game he still is young
obviously that's why you can play this
and they can get really really really
complicated now at the club level
normally your games won't get this
complicated because requires two people
to play this complicated of a game
however that's just the semi Slav even
when we're looking at the most
positional lines that are possible we
see some of the most fantastic games and
the most complicated strategically and
tactically positions that can ever arise
in chess which makes the semi Slav so
awesome and cool so let me know what you
guys think about these anti and Moran's
as always hit like share and subscribe
and thank you guys for coming and we'll
see you next week for another exciting
episode of the complete semi Slav
you
[Music]